[Musique]
vendredi soir sonner le début du ramadan
dans le monde entier
[Musique]
qui consiste à se priver de nourriture
de boissons et de rapports sexuels de
l'eau bouchée du soleil puis de 1000
musulmans étaient réunis sur Times
Square à New York pour rompre le jeûne
et pourrir ensemble
[Musique]
une image qui a fait le tour de la
planète alors qu'en France les prières
de rue peuvent être considérés comme des
troubles à l'ordre public alors des
musulmans réunis à New York pour
célébrer le ramadan est-ce que ce serait
possible en France
alors c'est incroyable je vais vous
montrer d'autres images regardez les new
yorkaisister à cette grande prière de
rue pour célébrer le début du ramadan
regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est incroyable franchement c'est
incroyable j'aurais jamais pu penser ça
moi dans la ville et c'est très beau
mais dans la ville du 11 septembre New
York c'est la la ville imaginer la même
situation vous prenez les Champs-Élysées
un trottoir j'ai vu comme ça se passe
bien vous avez vu comme ça se passe bien
en France vous le dis tout de suite
c'est carrément impossible là tout de
suite un quart de CRS qui va arriver de
car ils vont virer les 30 premières
personnes qui se réunissent elles sont
virées sur le champ donc Gilles je suis
pas du tout d'accord c'est possible mais
il faut le demander l'autorisation au
préfet mais les musulmans sont au
censure et ça c'est très bien parce que
c'est une manifestation de partage
musulman il avait déjà fait en 2017 à la
tour Trump et en 2019 dans un parc là
évidemment à Times Square ça prend des
proportions mondiales je trouve
formidable de tolérance d'enthousiasme
et de ferveur moi j'ai été bouleversé il
faut le faire il faut le faire à la
Concorde ce serait fantastique
une seconde
après c'est vrai que chacun voilà on me
dit à savoir moi je suis toujours pour
dire il faut être fier de sa religion
moi je suis fier de ceux qui vont à
l'église franchement je suis fier de
ceux qui je pense qu'il faut être fier
faut qu'il soit fier d'aller à l'église
de dire on va à l'église ceux qui vont à
la synagogue ceux qui vont à la mosquée
ceux qui vont ailleurs et ça pour moi
c'est magnifique parce que même les gens
qui ne connaissent pas je pense qu'ils
sont dit c'est incroyable je découvre
non mais c'est vrai c'est incroyable oui
oui vous dites NON Nicolas pernicov non
moi je dis non moi je dis qu'il y a des
il y a des lieux de culte et que c'est
l'espace public et que je suis pas
d'accord pour faire des grandes prières
comme ça géantes dans les rues que ce
soit à Paris
je pars du principe qu'il y a des lieux
de culte et que c'est de l'intimité
c'est sa faute
c'est très beau mais je j'y suis opposé
personnellement voilà c'est c'est mon
choix Kelly moi quand ça quand ça touche
la paix j'ai des là quand je vois ça
j'ai des frissons ça me plaît beaucoup
de voir ça vraiment mais je sais qu'en
France ce serait pas possible parce que
tout ce qui est religion c'est synonyme
de guerre voilà faut le dire je pense
qu'en France ce serait pas possible mais
quand je vois ça ouais j'ai des frissons
et ça me plaît énormément c'est
magnifique non ce sera impossible en
France parce qu'il y a un profond
malaise avec la religion musulmane
d'ailleurs toute la campagne elle se
fait là-dessus là non c'est pas vrai
vous faites la même chose sur les
Champs-Élysées il y aura forcément
quelqu'un qui va intervenir là ce qui
est très fort c'est que personne
n'intervient ni les passants ni les
autorités voilà c'est une très belle
preuve de vivre ensemble et
malheureusement en France ce serait pas
possible faut pas dire
parce que j'ai entendu une jeune comme
Kelly que j'adore Nicolas bon un peu
plus âgé mais formidable Guillaume aussi
qui qui est pourtant ouvert et tout de
suite ils disent non non on ne peut pas
c'est comme ça mais oui mais vous êtes
vous vous rétrécissez
que le lieu de culte c'est l'intimité il
y a des minorités dans les cultes je
veux dire à un moment donné chacun peut
aller dans son lieu de culte c'est sa
foi ces personnel je considère que c'est
intime on n'a pas le faire là voilà
c'est ce qu'on peut dire
dans le monde dans lequel on vit
actuellement
avec tout ce qu'on entend tout ce qu'on
voit je trouve que ça pour moi c'est une
image surtout à New York de paix
incroyable franchement c'est une image
exceptionnelle je pense que vous en
pensez mais je trouve que on a le droit
de pas croire et de trouver que ce
serait pas possible Kenny en fait
qu'elle vous dites j'ai pas qu'elle a
pas envie que ça se passe c'est qu'elle
porte ce ne serait pas possible elle
répond à la question
avec Fatou il est au bout de combien
en plus que je trouve que le symbole est
très beau après c'est vrai que Nicolas
ils font ça aussi pour Noël et ça
dérange et ça dérange personne donc dans
la symbolique c'est plutôt pas mal de
faire ça et c'est les grands temps qui
est en trainouka il faut il y a des
grands temps une fois pour parce que
musulmane c'est pas intégrisme c'est pas
tout ça et ça il y a un vrai problème et
en France malheureusement je finis le
vrai problème qu'il y a c'est que pour
le drapeau des gens parce qu'on en est
beaucoup de bêtises là dans les médias
etc c'est que les deux sont assimilés et
ça c'est terrible et c'est un Belge
effectivement vide il faut lutter contre
de toute notre force effectivement et ça
c'est un beau symbole mais ça on le fera
jamais en France plein de gens qui et
c'est ça qui est plein de gens qui
disent sur les réseaux c'est magnifique
mais comme Kelly il pense que ça ne
pourra jamais arriver en France parce
que ça ne sera pas possible voilà oui
Daniel on n'est pas prêt malheureusement
mais
il y a de énormément au 15 août et tout
ça et c'est très beau pourquoi on ne
pourrait pas faire ça
malheureusement
bien sûr il faut montrer sa
foi il y a rien de plus beau mais non on
peut plus mettre de sapin par exemple
dans les mairies dans les commentaires
n'importe quoi
aussi un traitement d'égalité
pour une grande messe à Noël voilà au
Trocadéro en faisant une grande
ouverture d'esprit avec cette grande
messe bien sûr je suis fou je suis pour
une énorme messe au Trocadéro ça serait
magnifique bien sûr
un truc dans la rue au Trocadéro je
trouve ça exceptionnel
un gros événement d'accord